wir machen uns auf die spuren unseres
eigenen verschwindens
verhüllte grabsteine in südafrika erst
wenn das geld für die abdankungsfeier
reicht werden sie enthüllt die identität
der verstorbenen wird sichtbar und sie
können endgültig gehen
zeichen einer transformation
fotografiert von virginia rometty
die westschweizer künstlerin lebt und
arbeitet in lausanne
seit über 15 jahren beschäftigt sie sich
fast ausschließlich mit dem thema tod
mich interessieren sich vor allem für
den raum zwischen leben und tod für
identitäten die noch nicht ganz beendet
sind
was bleibt nach dem tod übrig wie kann
man jemandem der nicht mehr da ist
wieder eine form geben
das sind die fragen die mich umtreiben
ausschlaggebend war ein tragisches
ereignissen ihre familie als ihre
großtante an krebs erkrankte sie fragte
mich ob ich ein letztes porträt von ihr
machen
das war ein sehr wichtiger moment für
meine weitere künstlerische arbeit denn
was bedeutet dass ein letztes bild
plötzlich hatte die fotografie einen
völlig anderen stellenwert für mich ihre
wegweisende arbeit heißt flirten bis
radon
dabei inszeniert sich die fotografen in
wohnungen von kürzlich verstorbenen
einzelgängern als wollte sie vermitteln
zwischen tod und leben
diese personen hatten völlig isoliert
gelebt hatten keine hinterbliebenen die
sich an sie erinnern würden ihr tod
falls ein richtiger schluss aber für
mich noch nicht ganz endgültig deshalb
kreierte ich diese fehlende erinnerung
die großformatigen bilder lässt die
36-jährige in einem genfer fotolabor
entwickeln an kleinen probe abzügen
werden farbe und helligkeit gesprochen
so auch an ihrer arbeit peking kleider
in denen menschen gestorben sind
sorgfältig zusammengelegt
diese kleider enthalten die letzten
momente eines menschenlebens das
zusammenlegen der kleider ist ein
symbolischer akt
denn es bezeichnet einerseits ein ende
andererseits ist es der beginn einer
neuen reise deshalb heißt die arbeit
auch ihre aktuelle arbeit heißt out of
the blue zu deutsch aus dem nichts
plötzlich so verschwand die 19 jährige
susanne 1998 in der nähe von new york
auch 17 jahre später ist immer noch
nicht klar was mit ihr passiert ist die
roboter untersucht diesen zustand der
unbehandelten identität
es war die erste arbeit war welche ich
auch mit hinterbliebenen in diesem fall
mit den eltern zu tun hat ich fragte
mich ständig ob ich das recht habe dies
zu tun
zb das gesicht der vermissten zu sein zu
verhüllen
es war mir einfach sehr wichtig dieser
tragischen geschichte mit dem nötigen
respekt zu begegnen
die fotokünstlerin sucht nach dem
unsichtbaren nach der seele eines
menschen für welchen ihr übel t lebt
diese nach dem tod weiter ich würde es
lieben wenn jemand nach meinem tod eine
künstlerische arbeit über mich machen
würde keine dokumentation sondern wenn
jemand irgendeinen aspekt meines lebens
nehmen und daraus etwas neues kreieren
würde
tod und erinnerung
leben und identität
die fotokunst von visionary bt
faszinierte auch weil man nicht an ein
leben nach dem tod glaubt
nächste woche fragen wir weshalb unsere
welt immer mehr aus den fugen